more than a year after HBO's Westworld
ended its sophomore season creators
Jonathan Nolan and Lisa joy are finally
taking the show to a place fans have
been waiting to see since the beginning
the real world
although Nolan is hinted that season 3
will be quote less of a guessing game
that doesn't mean the show will be any
less filled with intriguing Easter eggs
for sharp-eyed fans obviously spoilers
for all Westworld about Westworld takes
great care with its use of language
character names often carry a deeper
meaning well Teddy flood and Hester
eschaton surnames have ties to the end
of the world while Fortin bernard are
names that both appear on all thus
Huxley's dystopian novel brave new world
board being Henry Ford and in the novel
another word for God while Bernard is an
alpha male resentful of his inability to
fit into society
likewise episode titles often point to
something deeper like season Ones
contrapasso which is a reference to the
punishment of souls in Dante's Inferno
West world's third season puts another
biblical reference front and center in
the premiere episode titled part a
Domini
it's a Roman Catholic antiphon or chant
and it comes from the book of Joel
translation reads spare Lord spare your
people lest you be angry with us forever
it's commonly heard during the lent
season the time in which Christians fast
and forgo physical pleasures as a means
of recognizing Christ 40-day journey
into the desert for West world the
significance is twofold
it could be representative of Dolores
his long journey into the real world as
she has already set herself up as the
host Savior it's also a call to be
spared from a holy wrath to be granted
mercy something Dolores likely won't
deliver after all real gods are coming
never angry when we first meet Caleb it
says he wakes up to begin his day much
of what we see of Caleb is routine he
goes through the motions of his life
almost as if he's on a loop it doesn't
take much to recognize the similarities
between Caleb and the host mave we met
in season 1
just as Maeve did in West world's first
season it's a pretty safe bet that Caleb
will wind up waking up from his reality
in the coming weeks
[Music]
but Caleb isn't the only Westworld
character following a familiar path by
the end of the episode Dolores has
successfully replaced Martin Connells
the head of security for insight with a
host under her control insights of
course is the data company that controls
the system I think Dolores would very
much like access to so now Dolores has a
host posing as a high-ranking dello
sport member along with one who works
high-level security if we bind into
theory that Stubbs was an undercover
host within the west-world theme park
then it's looking like Dolores is
working her own port magic in the real
world with her own Arnold Bernhard and
Stubbs stand-ins what's become a Bernard
since he made his way back to the real
world and had that ominous first meeting
with Dolores turns out he isn't doing so
well having gone into hiding following
the west-world Massacre Bernard has been
spending the last few months living and
working on a meat farm the slaughtering
of animals his work he has some trouble
with but he makes do at least until he's
confronted by a couple of co-workers and
is forced to switch personalities in
order to handle the situation Bernard it
seems is able to switch between
personalities at the touch of a button
or more accurately he can alternate
between his character and analysis modes
which have evolved into distinct
personalities it looks like much of his
arc this season will be in trying to put
himself back together and if you need
hard evidence you don't have to look any
further than the name he's using as an
alias it's an anagram for damaged Arnold
well it isn't necessarily a grand theft
auto easter-egg Rico the app Kaleb uses
to make money in its downtime does
certainly feel like a nod to the famous
video game with tons of quick buck
options and messages like you made Bank
now get drank it definitely evokes a GTA
vibe this wouldn't be the first time the
series has been compared to the game
either during its first season deadline
like in West world to being quote more
Grand Theft Auto than the emmy-winning
Game of Thrones in fact Jonathan Nolan
even cited the game as a reference at
the 2016 New York Comic Con saying we
played some his research for making the
show as when michael crichton first
wrote his movie videogames literally
didn't exist except for pong I'm happy
to report my wife is the world's most
boring Grand Theft Auto player check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]